Okay.
>> My name is Aayou Na and I'm a host wife
and I'm I'm actually represent a
question from my American non-Muslim
that cannot attend to this event
tonight. And for the question is I mean
she said about this like how people go
to heaven like uh she heard some Muslims
say they will all go to heaven
eventually even if they have to spend
some time in hell and then others say
that no one knows if they will ever get
to heaven. So what does the Quran say
about that? So yeah that's the question.
Thank you
>> the sister. the question that one of our
American non-Muslim friends
>> yes
>> she asked that you know that the Muslims
even if they do something wrong
eventually they'll go to heaven is this
correct
>> like
>> that's the main question
>> um yeah because uh like
uh where some Muslims say like the
Muslims say they will all go to heaven
but some of it also say like oh uh even
uh even if if they're a Muslim him and
they have like uh they will go to heaven
but they need to go to the hell first
and then go to heaven later like that.
>> Yes, I understood your question.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
>> The question if some Muslim do sin.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> They will go to hell for some time and
finally go to heaven. Is it correct?
>> Yeah. Allah says in the Quran in surah
Nisar 4:48 and surah Nisa 4 verse number
if Allah pleases he may forgive any sin
but the sin of shik he will never
forgive
mean if you associate partners with God
Allah will never forgive you so if
anyone who's a non-Muslim
who associate partners with God he will
never be forgiven however goody because
this is the biggest sin in Islam
yourself.
>> Now those people who are Muslims who do
any other sin besides shik if Allah
pleases he may forgive
the sin of shik is the biggest sin which
Allah will never forgive unless you
rectify before you die. you you become
you say that you you followed before you
die different but if you die as a mushik
you will never be forgiven 100% hell but
those Muslims
who then tell to the non-Muslim oh
finally I'll go to heaven they also big
fools
means staying in hell is no joke
>> yeah yeah yeah
>> you can't stay for a minute live for
years so these people who say finally
we'll go to heaven also fools but lesser
fools than the non-Muslims.
Non-Muslim will be in hell forever.
Those Muslims who don't follow the Quran
and only don't do shik follow part of
the Quran but do many sins like drinking
alcohol, murdering, cheating, they'll be
punished in the hellfire but finally
they will go to hell but they'll become
like charcoal you know charcoal.
So it's not hell is no joke. So those
who say finally we'll go to he hell
heaven they don't know that staying in
hell even for a second is not easy. So
that's the we strive when we pray to
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala may he forgive
our sins. We try and do more good deeds
so that the small sins we do Allah will
forgive. So Allah says in the Quran stay
away from the major sins and Allah will
forgive your minor sins. And there's a
book written by Imam Abdhabi the 70
major sins. So Muslims should be careful
that we should not be involved in shik.
We should always pray salah. We should
give zakat fast in the month of Ramadan.
Perform Hajj, love and respect our
parents.
See to it that you don't do machuality,
don't do zena, all the order. Don't take
I'm going in order. You understand now?
>> So we Muslims should see to that we
follow as much as the guidance of the
Quran and the hadith and inshallah see
to it that we away from major sins.
Inshallah, Allah will forgive your minor
sins. Hope that answers the question.
>> Okay. Thank you so much.